Maastricht Holland where apparently cars
parked themselves sweet car but where's
the driver we've seen driverless cars
before and they're normally packed with
wires and electronics but in this case
we can't see any controls and it's doing
donuts created by Bjorn harms he claims
he's controlling this full-size muscle
car using just an RC controller I just
don't get how he's doing it I can't see
any motors or controls this looks really
advanced I love this clip I don't care
if it's real or fake don't even tell me
we went to Holland to find out if this
car really is being controlled remotely
I think it's real I'm not remotely
convinced by this Chellis Bjorn is this
really a remote-controlled car or is
this v8 a fake there are a lot of people
that think that is fake it really isn't
it's an RC car with 404 horsepower it's
just crazy
definitely this is epic this is rad yeah
we think so too
but how is this Corvette control the
Orang had a dream of building a
full-sized remote-control car so he took
his own sports car and modify it so it
could be driven remotely and manually
the difference between my RC car and
other cars that are also RC control is
that Bill old servos all the motors
inside the dashboard and on the controls
so that the interior looks completely
stuck I can't believe this guy's done it
all by himself
it looks seamless Bjorn has a radio
controller in his hands that sends radio
waves to receiver in the glovebox those
signals are decoded and then they send
various signals to all the components to
control the car to steer the car back
and forth Bjorn sends a signal to the
receiver which drives it motor located
under the dashboard this other motor
moves the steering wheel and therefore
the tires now as you can see this wheel
turn us the wheel disk control changed
the gear so if your wants the car to
accelerate he sends that signal with his
controller to the receiver the receiver
then talks to the motor which then moves
a lever that pushes the accelerator and
of course braking and throttle
due to the speed of the radio signals
and the processor there's virtually no
delay however a full-size car will react
a lot slower than a toy car equivalent
because of its increased size and mass
with more mass it means it has more
inertia and that means it greater
resistance to a change in motion in
contrast to how he would break a small
remote-control car he has to break his
Corvette a lot earlier driving is pretty
hard on a full scale car
you gotta get a feel for the braking and
not slamming it with your finger so in
the end Jordans biggest limitation is
his own reaction time but because of his
epic driving skills he's been able to
pull this off